bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi
mission accomplie pour la nasa à 130
millions de km de la terre elle est
parvenue à percuter avec une sonde la
comète tempel 1 pour en percer les
secrets les données recueillies vont
maintenant permettre de mieux comprendre
la formation du système solaire
après la chaleur les trombes d'eau de
très violents orages ont frappé la
moitié nord de la france les inondations
provoquées de grosses difficultés de
circulation autour de lille et de paris
l'europe de l'est est aussi touché 12
morts en roumanie et en bulgarie crise
de joie ou crises de larmes
les premiers résultats du bac qui ont
été affichés aujourd'hui la plus jeune
diplômé s'appelle lni elle a 13 ans elle
a décroché son bac scientifique avec 11
sur 20 de moyenne
le procès de david hotyat le meurtrier
présumé de la famille flactif dans le
chalet du grand bornand comparer cette
fois pour des dizaines de vols commis
avant et après le crime une audience qui
met en évidence la personnalité du
prévenu
l'aide publique des pays riches
peut-elle sortir l'afrique de la
pauvreté c'est le débat ouvert à l'avant
veille du g 8 en écosse
la grande bretagne et les etats unis
sont décidés à faire un geste mais il
réclame des garanties de bonne gestion
de la part des dirigeants africains
enfin la guerre des nerfs entre londres
et paris
les deux favoris à deux jours de la
décision du comité sur l'organisation
des jeux olympiques en 2012
les petites piques se multiplient à
singapour tony blair fait le forcing
il rencontre en tête à tête une
vingtaine de membres du cio jacques
chirac sera sur place demain matin le 4
juillet le jour de la fête nationale
américaine
eh bien il marquera aussi désormais une
nouvelle date dans la conquête spatiale
la nasa en effet réussi son pari elle a
projeté une charge contre une comète
tout s'est passé exactement comme prévu
agnès menteuse la cible est en vue à
trente-sept mille kilomètres heure le
missile cosmique fond sur la comète
tempel 1
la première mission kamikaze
interstellaire et photographié jusqu'au
dernier instant jusqu'au crash violent
comme en témoigne ce cliché pris par la
sonde deep impact
restez à distance
sur terre c'est une autre explosion de
joie selma la nasa a réussi l'incroyable
défi de faire un trou dans une comète
c'était sûrement un gros chèque nous
avons probablement un grand cratère que
nous verrons sur des images que nous
n'avons pas encore reçu donc plein comme
tout les comètes c'est une énorme pomme
de terre sable un amas de glace et de
poussières primitif qui remonte aux
origines de notre système solaire
l'idée en la percutant c'est de faire
ressortir les couches l'intérieur
d'étudier les poussières qui témoignent
du passé de notre système solaire
voilà pourquoi les télescopes du monde
entier dans l'espace ou sur la terre
sont braqués sur cette petite comète
véritables archives de notre système
solaire avant la formation des planètes
son étude devrait permettre au
spécialiste de remonter le temps de
mieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé il y
a quatre milliards et demi d'années
et puis il ya aussi l'exploit technique
l'échelle d'une planète la comète tempel
1 est minuscule c'est un gros caillou
glacé de 14 km sur 6 alors comment la
cible at elle était atteinte si loin de
la terre nicolas chateauneuf florent des
bois
l'histoire d'oedipe l'impact commence le
12 janvier dernier
lancé depuis la floride la sonde va
alors entamer une gigantesque courbe
dans l'espace de 430 millions de
kilomètres plus de mille fois la
distance terre lune
son objectif une comète tempel-1 une
boule de neige sale de 14 km de long sur
6 de large
heureusement celle-ci suit tous les cinq
ans la même trajectoire
il est donc facile pour les
scientifiques de calculer l'endroit
exact du rendez vous les difficultés ont
vraiment commencé hier lorsque la sonde
a largué un petit robot un facteur 1 900
mille kilomètres de la comète
un peu comme si sur terre on voulait
atteindre une cible d'un mètre de
diamètre de paris à rouen
faut impérativement que cet impact
heures soit intelligent et un système de
navigation autonome une caméra un
logiciel qui va repérer la cible sur
l'image et puis des propulseurs pour
dévier la trajectoire automatiquement
sans aucune intervention de la terre
résultat une comète percuté exactement
là où on l'attendait mais deep impact
n'est qu'un avant goût d'une autre
mission encore plus ambitieuse menée
cette fois par les européens
son nom et rosetta elle a été lancée
l'année dernière
son objectif n'est plus de s'écraser sur
une comète mais de se mettre en orbite
autour et d'y poser un petit robot d'
analyse le seul problème c'est qu'il
faudra attendre 2014 pour profiter du
spectacle
et en attendant prochain rendez vous
pour la nasa ce sera le 13 juillet avec
la relance des vols de la navette
spatiale en france on est passé en
quelques jours des grandes chaleurs aux
trombes d'eau de l'eau qui est montée
jusqu'à 1 mètre cinquante à hazebrouck
des autoroutes transformées en rivières
lille a été la grande ville la plus
touchée les orages ont surpris presque
tout le monde frédéric vion patrick
buros thorn
c'est sans doute la première fois qu'on
se déplace en bateau à cet endroit car
nous ne sommes pas sur un lac mais bien
sûr une auto il s'agit plus précisément
de la voie rapide lille roubaix où il a
suffi de quelques dizaines de minutes ce
matin pour que l'eau atteigne plus d'un
mètre cinquante par endroits un orage
dont la violence a surpris en pleine
heure de pointe les automobilistes
coincés dans les embouteillage
certains ont pu redémarrer d'autres non
en l'espace de même pas une minute que
l'eau a commencé à monter
bon ben l'eau arrivant au niveau de
comment dire du volant bas on a dû le
s'est engouffré on a dû fêter nos
véhicules qu ils vous voudrez sur la
sellette blanche la voilà c'est ça qu'on
voit
blanquefort depuis minuit et jusqu'à 11
heures ce matin les orages ont balayé la
région d'ouest en est
transformant les égouts les toilettes ou
les douches en geyser d'eau boueuse
une eau qui dans certaines maisons et
monte à près d'un mètre au
rez-de-chaussée faisant sauter les
disjoncteurs et dévastant tout les
pompiers bien sûr ont été très
sollicités dans sept régions peu
habituées à des crues aussi subite après
la fois que ça vous arrive en 27 ans de
cette ampleur là oui la vie déjà eu
quand même une moindre entre la rue des
inondations mais ça se limiter aux
jardins tout au long de la journée la
pluie et les fermetures de routes ont
entraîné de nombreux bouchons notamment
autour de l'île avant que l'on ne
commence à baisser dans l'après midi
ce soir le trafic est presque partout
revenue à la normale
sous un ciel redevenu bleus et on l'a
entendu c'est l'ensemble du
nord-pas-de-calais qui a été frappé par
les orages ainsi que la belgique voisine
il a fallu évacuer des campings mettre
des centaines de personnes en sécurité
florence bouclier ce matin la pluie
tombe est encore dans le pas de calais
quatre campings ont été évacués
200 touristes mises à l'abri dans des
gymnases les pompiers du département ont
dû intervenir à plus de 300 reprises
dans les habitations et les câbles non
loin de là en belgique
c'est le même orage aussi violent qui a
surpris tout le monde des pluies
torrentielles des dizaines de routes de
maisons d'entrepôts noyer il a à peu
près un mètre cinquante d'eau pour
générer terrible dans cette région à
l'ouest défendre la surprise n'en
portent sur l'inquiétude dans toute ma
vie explique cette femme je n'ai jamais
vu ça et pourtant ça fait plus de 60 ans
que je suis ici la nuit d'hier a été dur
aussi pour les pompiers belges appelés
un peu partout à l'aide souvent bloqués
sur des routes totalement inondées toute
la nuit
de nombreux habitants ont été contraints
à la patience une partie de l'europe à
l'est notamment a été plus durement
frappé encore ici en bulgarie quatre
personnes ont été tuées par la foudre
dans le sud et l'est du pays notamment
un homme qui réparait cette fois un
autre est mort noyé on signale par
ailleurs qu'elle débordement d'un
barrage a provoqué la disparition de
plusieurs troupeaux et puis en roumanie
voisine le bilan est encore plus lourd
on compte sept victimes
c'est le début des vacances pour la
plupart pour les autres il faudra encore
révisées en vue de l'oral de rattrapage
les résultats du bac ont été affichés
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des
académies françois jullien pieds noirs à
paris avec francis mazier à marseille
ils ont tous un drôle de comportement
depuis ce matin pas de panique c'est
l'effet bac on saute dans tous les sens
à bordeaux ou à paris on ne sait plus si
l'on pleure d'échec ou de victoire
je pense être en attraper les larmes de
papa elles sont de joie au travail et
surtout une cabine beau c'est beau ce
lycée parisien 90% de réussite on a
d'autant plus de fierté à avoir son bac
quand on a été un cancre toute l'année
moi je les ouvre
le bac c'est l'aboutissement d'un an de
travail que dis-je de toute une
scolarité
une fois son bac en poche on cherche les
copains sur la liste il faut s'assurer
qu'ils font aussi partie de la fête
malheureusement leurs copines hortense
ne sortira pas ce soir elle est au
rattrapage comme 10% des élèves de ce
lycée
les épreuves commencent dès demain les
professeurs prodiguent leurs derniers
conseils appréciation favorable
au niveau du jury il ya de bonnes
chances il faut y aller un peu
décontractée la meilleure méthode c'est
de repérer au contraire là où ils ont eu
des points très faible vous confrères et
dans les disciplines qui sont affectés
d'un gros coefficients fait ils sont
seulement 4 recalé à ne pas faire la
fête ce soir
les autres peuvent partir en vacances et
sachez que la plus jeune des candidates
a décroché son bac elle s'appelle et
laignel à 13 ans elle a obtenu 11 sur 20
de moyenne générale et elle se dit déçue
car elles espéraient une mention
et puis à noter qu'à rouen les résultats
ont été livrés avec deux jours d'avancé
sur internet car un pirate informatique
a réussi à pénétrer dans le site de
l'éducation nationale il a déjoué les
codes d'accès ceux qui passeront l'oral
de rattrapage auront donc bénéficier
deux 48 heures de plus pour réviser
cette journée est éprouvante pour les
nerfs pour les lycéens comme pour leurs
parents et pourtant il est toujours bon
de le rappeler même s'il est très utile
on peut toujours s'en sortir sans le bac
les exemples plus ou moins célèbres ne
manquent pas fanny au vernis alain duban
recalé au bac
certains élèves ce matin ont appris une
mauvaise nouvelle là je vais tout faire
pour l'avoir l'année prochaine et
pourquoi ne pas continuer en disant
qu'il yad'autres voir
c'est quand même bien d'avoir un minimum
à un mac quand même c'est une ouverture
pourtant certains ont réussi dans la vie
active sans le fameux diplôme comme jean
bousquet en 1962 avec un ca paix en
poche et sans le bac il fonde la maison
de couture cacharel
aujourd'hui ces vêtements sont vendus
dans le monde entier mais quelles sont
les clés d'une telle réussite
il faut de la volonté il faut la
confiance beaucoup d'audace mais il ya
beaucoup donné cher beaucoup de
possibilités pour réussir il ya qu à
regarder le débat est aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens son côté qu' on part
pas forcément l'unc
quels que soient les secteurs d'activité
de nombreux autodidacte rencontre le
succès en politique par exemple jean
louis debré
christian estrosi ou encore rené monory
n'ont jamais obtenu leur baccalauréat
même réussite dans le monde des affaires
pour françois pinault jean claude decaux
ou alain dominique perrin
mais l'éducation nationale offre une
nouvelle chance aux candidats malheureux
deux formations possibles
la capacité en droit ou le diplôme
d'accès aux études universitaires
permettent de s'inscrire à la fac
malgré tout et puis un mot du concours
général cuvée 2005 qui récompense vous
le savez comme chaque année les
meilleurs des lycéens de première et de
terminale 146 prix ont été décernés cela
va du latin aux travaux publics en
passant par l'histoire géo ou l'italien
pas de surprise pour le palmarès des
lycées les plus récompensées louis le
grand à paris devant ce henri iv
toujours à paris justice avec le procès
de david hotyat le meurtrier présumé de
la famille flactif dans le chalet du
grand bornand il ne s'agit pas cette
fois de juger les crimes mais les vols à
répétition dont est soupçonné le prévenu
des vols commis avant et après le
meurtre stéphanie labrousse thierry
monnier sur place c'est une affaire qui
s'articule autour des quatre
protagonistes des dossiers flactif david
hotyat meurtrier présumé
son complice présumé stéphane arena et
leurs compagnes à leur côté sept autres
prévenus de la famille et des amis
tout un petit monde accusée de vol et
recel en haute savoie entre 2002 et 2003
voiture mobilier électroménager
des balles ont même été commis au chalet
des flactif après le quintuple meurtre
ce sont des services e rentrée
impunément après le crime et se sont
servis puisque ocha bien dit arena qui
peut prendre ce que tu veux
l'ombre du volet criminel plane sur ce
procès de correctionnelle
david hotyat reconnaîtra les à deux
reprises au chalet des flactif après le
drame la première fois parce qu'on m'a
demandé de faire disparaître des
documents explique-t-il qui deux
inconnus
les deux hommes dont il n'a eu de cesse
de parler depuis qu'il s'est décidé à
dire les choses dans le cadre de
l'instruction criminelle
les deux inconnus là j'ai bien
l'impression vous en vous emplit est un
tout petit peu sur le faire rémunérer ta
question pour la décence d'aborder
aujourd'hui le volet criminel face aux
avocats des parties civiles
david hotyat s'est agacé on a les procès
verbaux du dossier criminel qui sont là
donc on lui demande des explications
pour sa salle 10 à lui déplaît joue bien
qui disent carrément joué par exemple
parce que j'ai pas envie de répondre
mais là nous dire nous sommes le son
droit nous expliquons plein de choses je
vous c'est ridicule les jugements de ce
procès pour vol et recel devraient être
connus demain soir je sis encore pendant
des années la gérante d'une agence
immobilière avait écarté les étrangers
ou les personnes d'origine étrangère des
offres de logement le procès pour
discrimination avait lieu cet après midi
à toulouse la gérante se défend en
indiquant qu'elle agissait à la demande
des propriétaires
yvan martin et david bres pendant près
d'un an cette jeune femme a refusé aux
étrangers des offres de location les
consignes de sa patronne était clair ni
noir ni maghrébin sur la fiche
descriptive des de la location est
marquée pe qui voulait dire pas
d'étrangers dans ces cas là que ce que
vous faisiez et on devait trouver
n'importe quelle excuse par rapport à ce
qu'on savait du client qui est en face
de nos pour pas leur donner place du
capitole cette société avait pourtant
pignon sur rue pe pas d'étranger
traitement sion aurait figuré
sur des centaines d'annoncés est ici à
toulouse il ya eu beaucoup de procès
contre des agences immobilières elle
savait ce qu'elle risque et elle savait
que quelques hommes étaient comme des
dix sept l'agencement le bien doit être
lourdement sanctionnés la responsable de
l'agencé
elle reconnaît les faits moi comme chez
quinze mille propriétaires
ça m'est difficile de retenir call
propriétaire va bien accueillir un
client à moi qui est d'origine étrangère
ou mal l'accueillir donc je janot s'est
effectivement je mettais cette petite
mention uniquement dans l'intérêt des
dénés client d'origine étrangère
poursuivi pour discrimination elle
encourt une peine de trois ans de prison
et 45000 euros d'amendé
les propriétaires eux ne seront pas
inquiétés si dans la salle d'audience ce
soir il n'y a qu'un plaignant et kahn
accusé alors qu'ils pourraient être des
centaines c'est parce que la police a
renoncé à rechercher l'ensemble des
protagonistes jugeant dé mesurer
l'ampleur d'une telle tâche
la réforme de la filiation deux siècles
après la création du code civil une
ordonnance présentée en conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui supprime la
distinction entre enfants naturels et
enfants légitimes
il s'agit de mettre en accord les moeurs
et les textes puisqu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui près de la moitié des
enfants naissent hors mariage
dominique tchimbakala baer dynario
bientôt tous les enfants nés trop libres
et égaux en droits enfin légitime
enfants naturels il n'y aura plus aucune
distinction
c'est l'aboutissement d'un parcours long
de plusieurs siècles et l'histoire de
france a eu bien des bâtards célèbre de
guillaume le conquérant duc de normandie
aux nombreux enfants de louis xiv avec
madame de montespan enfant adultérin qui
n'avait donc pas le droit à l'héritage
jusqu'en 1972 et considéré comme
légitime tout enfant né d'un couple
marié et enfin naturel celui né hors
mariage
et depuis trente ans les lois se sont
succédé pour donner à tous les mêmes
droits le droit d' à vous d'être élevé
par ses parents le droit d'avoir
également l'autorité que son père puisse
partager les responsabilités avec la mer
même s'ils n'ont pas été marié cedac
l'autorité parentale
tiens aux deux parents et dernièrement
en 2001 la loi sur les successions qui a
donné une égalité aux enfants
aujourd'hui en france un enfant sur deux
nés hors mariage
une tendance qui se généralise en europe
la suppression du distinguo légitime
naturel entérine donc un fait de société
et simplifiera la vie de tous les
enfants et de leurs parents
la réunion à evian aujourd'hui des
ministres de l'intérieur français
italiens espagnols allemands et
britanniques ce qu'on appelle le g5
c'est à dire les pays fondateurs de
l'espace schengen sur la sécurité
principal sujet abordé aujourd'hui
l'immigration clandestine des mesures de
coordination doivent être adoptées par
exemple retenir les empreintes des mêmes
doigts sur les fichiers pour faciliter
les comparaisons
ça paraît évident et pourtant lé
gouvernement en tout 47 font face aux
mêmes types de difficultés en france
l'une de nos équipes est retourné à
calais il y a trois ans des centaines
des milliers de clandestins affluer dans
la région pour passer en grande-bretagne
où leurs conditions de vie étaient plus
favorables
c'était l'époque du fameux centre de
sangatte aujourd'hui ce centre n'existe
plus le problème est en partie réglé en
partie seulement enquête loïc de la
mornais nicolas aubert
rien ne les a empêché de revenir en
pleine ville 150 clandestins se pressent
à la distribution de nourriture du midi
organisées quotidiennement
quel tant bien que mal par les
associations d'entre elles
au milieu de la distribution nous
croisons un confrère stanley des
photojournalistes au nigeria il est en
france sans papiers depuis trois ans
j'ai fait des photos d'une milice
inféodée au pouvoir
ça m'a causé beaucoup de problèmes et
j'ai dû fuir c'est une histoire longue à
raconter et aujourd'hui encore
ça me fait pleurer il y a encore
quelques semaines à 50 mètres de là ce
hangar et cette cour était un véritable
camp de réfugiés dissimulé en pleine
ville venus d'iran d'irak d'afghanistan
ou de somalie
plus de 200 personnes s'y entassent m la
police a démantelé les lieux au grand
désespoir des associations et qui ces
pays là parce que c'est ils sont dans de
très grandes difficultés donc c'est pas
de fermer un centre c'est pas de faire
une traque effrénée aux sans papiers qui
va empêcher des gens de quitter leur
pays en difficulté à plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres depuis la fermeture de
sangatte il y a moins de clandestins à
calais mais le problème n'a pas disparu
il s'est plutôt dispersé à l'image des
communautés dans la ville ici sous ce
pont c'est le coin des afghans là dans
ce hangar désaffecté celui des kurdes
parfois entre communautés de clandestins
les tensions éclatent ce soir à la
distribution de 19 heures une bagarre a
opposé un passeur kurdes à un afghan les
deux communautés viennent de s'affronter
à coups de bâtons la distribution
reprend sous l'oeil distants des
autorités
situation ubuesque où la police c'est
tout trouvé des clandestins mais ne les
arrête pas ils sont souvent
inexpulsables vers leur pays d'origine
mais on ne peut les laisser partir vers
l'angleterre ce soir haussmann et ses
amis iraniens campe à quelques centaines
de mètres de ces ferries qui les font
rêver
l'accès au bateau est devenu beaucoup
plus difficile autrefois 200 clandestins
traverser la manche chaque nuit contre
seulement six ou sept aujourd'hui
souvent la police et attrapes mais à
chaque fois ils reviennent il nous
emmène pour nous relâcher à 2 100 ou 120
kilomètres d'ici on revient à pied
pourquoi ils font ça
cette nuit encore de nombreuses ombres
essaieront de se faufiler haussmann lui
ne réussira pas ce soir alors ils
chantent face à son eldorado anglais à
monaco la décision très attendue du
prince albert il devrait annoncer en
milieu de semaine la reconnaissance d'un
enfant naturel un garçon de 22 mois né
d'une liaison avec une hôtesse de l'air
cette dernière avait rompu le secret il
y a deux mois
l'enfant serait alors l'héritier d'une
partie de la fortune mais cette
reconnaissance ne changerait rien à
l'ordre de succession anouk burel
raymond schappler c'est un communiqué
qui pourrait bouleverser la tranquillité
du rocher après trois mois de deuil
la principauté de monaco s'apprête à
entendre que le prince albert a bien un
fils de 200 alexandre son visage a été
révélée par paris match le 4 mai dernier
sa mère une ancienne hôtesse de l'air
voulait que le prince assume ses
responsabilités c'est tout à fait
honorable de sa part
efraim là chacun aussi nos vies privées
et bon bah c'est son histoire à lui
c'est sa réalité sa réalité
jusqu'ici elle avait été plutôt discrète
mais une semaine avant son intronisation
officielle
albert ii aurait décidé d'imposer son
autorité
c'est une décision extrêmement
courageuse qui doit pas faire plaisir à
tout le monde il faut pas se leurrer
quand il est arrivé c'est vrai que les
conseillers extrêmement conservateur de
son père qui sont encore en place ne
voient sûrement pas tout ça d'un très
bon oeil pour lui c'est une manière de
s'affirmer dia voilà aujourd'hui mais
c'est moi qui suis aux commandes la
reconnaissance officielle ne permettra
pas pour autant à alexandre de devenir
prince héritier en 2002 régnier a fait
modifier la constitution monégasque un
enfant conçu hors mariage ne pourra
jamais accédé aux dieux que qui que ce
soit et sa connaissance peut pas briguer
le poste le 30 et grimaldi et sahara est
née la nation anticipé de quelques
manières que ce soit si ce n'est pour
cet enfant là pour tous les enfants
possible d'adopter un objectif l'albert
qui est et qui est toujours célibataire
si le prince albert reconnaît sa
paternité
le petit alexandre sera en tout cas l'un
des héritiers de la fortune princière
estimé à 2 milliards d'euros
les préparatifs du sommet des huit pays
les plus industrialisés en écosse le g8
qui débutera après demain journée
marquée aujourd'hui encore par des
manifestations pacifistes la base de
fast lane port d'attache des sous marins
nucléaires britanniques a été bloquée
tandis que vous le voyez des bagarres
avaient lieu à edimbourg mais le
principal sujet de discussion portera on
l'a déjà dit dès la semaine dernière sur
la pauvreté en afrique
depuis trente ans la chine l'inde la
plupart des pays d'asie et d'amérique
latine ont pris leur envol le continent
africain lui reste à l'écart question
qui sera au coeur du sommet la solution
peut-elle venir de l'aide publique au
développement
il ya quelques années encore c'était une
évidence aujourd'hui on considère que ce
n'est plus une formule magique ou en
tout cas que l'utilisation de cette aide
doit être conditionnée ou même contrôlé
richard binet gilles jacquier
1250 milliards de dollars l'équivalent
du budget de la france
le total de l'aide publique versée au
continent noir depuis son indépendance
en 1960
et pourtant 45 ans plus tard un africain
sur deux vit encore avec moins d'un euro
par jour et 15 mille enfants meurent au
quotidien victimes de la pauvreté
l'annulation de la dette octroyés au
départ pour favoriser le décollage
économique des pays pauvres
les prêts accordés sont devenus une
entrave à leur développement
le poids de la dette est telle qu'en
ethiopie au niger ou en zambie le
remboursement des seuls intérêts
dépassent les budgets de la santé et de
l'éducation remini de pénalité en
réaménagement les états africains ont
repoussé plusieurs fois le capital pour
1 euros empruntés en 1981 il devrait
rembourser aujourd'hui 5 sans être pour
autant libérer de la dette une aide sous
condition
après les indépendances les élites
africaines ont voulu copier le modèle
occidental fait somptuaires
constructions pharaoniques comme cette
reproduction de la basilique
saint-pierre en côte d'ivoire sans que
la communauté internationale ne
s'inquiète de la destination de l'aide
apportée des millions de dollars se sont
envolés vers l'étranger la corruption a
gangrené l'économie je ne pense pas que
l'argent facile face le bonheur de
l'afrique parce que d'une part l'aide
mais d'autre part aussi les rangs tirés
du pétrole où par exemple les récits de
richesses minières n'ont rien donné dans
des pays qui ont tué cet argent facile
par exemple les nigériens à lui depuis
l'indépendance 300 milliards de dollars
il n'y a pas d'équivalent dans le pays
en terme d'une usine ou d'équipements
sociaux pour cet argent réintégrer
l'afrique dans l'économie mondiale
aucune mesure ne sera efficace sans une
redéfinition des rapports entre le nord
et le sud
à quoi sert sous couvert de compassion
d'aider ces paysans maliens
si dans le même temps les pays riches
subventionne à grands frais leur propre
agriculture
le président bush s'est fait le héraut
de ce nouveau concept
si les marchés occidentaux sont ouverts
aux pays africains at-il dit ce matin
cela leur réussira et il n'y aura plus
besoin de leur verser des aides
une position qu'il dépendra
vraisemblablement lors du sommet du g8
mercredi en écosse
illustration en tout cas de ce débat sur
l'aide au sommet de l'union africaine en
libye plusieurs représentants des pays
d'afrique se sont opposés à l'aide
étrangère considéré comme de la
mendicité c'est le terme qui a été
employé nous ne voulons pas être
infantiliser par cette campagne par
exemple expliqué un analyste nigérian
les jeux olympiques 2012 c'est dans
moins de 48 heures qu'on connaîtra la
décision du comité jour j - 2 et la
guerre des nerfs entre londres et paris
a commencé à singapour les petites
piques se multiplient tony blair fait le
forcing
il a choisi de rencontrer en tête à tête
une vingtaine de membres du cio manuel
sicié vincent bouffartigue sur place à
singapour
est ce que mon les biens reculent et
merci la pression monte et le candidat
parisien tente de résister autour du
maire et du ministre
paris-2012 mène la bataille de singapour
l'ennemi n'est jamais nommé
mais il est dans toutes les têtes
londres et sa tactique de harcèlement du
seuil haut provoque une colère contenue
et un coût de grille nous respectons les
règles
d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas demandé les
rendez-vous aux membres du cio puisque
ce n'est pas permis
mais nous pouvons les rencontres et puis
certains ont envie de nous voir mais
tout ça dans un climat qui n'est pas un
climat commercial commercial comme la
démarche de tony blair qui va recevoir
un par un tous les membres votants un
porte-à-porte offensif à l'image du
numéro 1 de londres 2012 sebastian coe
ne manque jamais l'occasion de pointer
la nature très politique des leaders
parisien les politiciens sont à leur
place
cela dit le double champion olympique de
15 ans m londres serait telle agressive
et arrogante
venant d'un journaliste français la
question amuse sebastian coe c'est le
monde à l'envers
lance-t-il sous les rires anglais les
autres candidats restent de marbre
devant les chamailleries franco anglaise
new york par exemple n'a pas dit son
dernier mot et le scénario d'une finale
paris londres fait doucement rire les
spécialistes
quiconque affirme que la course se
résume à un duel paris-londres a fumé
quelque chose de bizarre je ne sais pas
quoi
quiconque peut dire ce qui se passera
dans deux jours à fumer quelque chose
d'encore plus fort dans le salon du raf
plaza
tout est prêt pour les pilotes de cette
campagne qui aura duré plus de deux ans
après les dernières répétitions
d'aujourd'hui
la salle est interdite aux caméras
jusqu'à mercredi matin en 48 heures un
vainqueur franchira ses portes un seul
vainqueur
car à ce jeu là il n'y a pas de podium
une médaille d'or et quatre perdants et
vous l'entendrez bien sûr en direct sur
france 2 et puis aux côtés du premier
ministre britannique les stars anglaises
ont également fait le déplacement
c'est le cas du couple le plus célèbre
du pays après charles et camilla il
s'agit de david beckham et de victoria
le footballeur est venu en famille
supporter la candidature de londres des
stars aussi mais dans le camp français
cette fois tony parker marie jo pérec ou
laura flessel ont pris l'avion ensemble
tout à l'heure roma mais si philippe
chasselas
un palmarès français à faire rêver pour
séduire une délégation de sportifs
prestigieux réunis autour d'une même
ambition voir les jeux à paris quand on
a eu le bonheur de vivre les jeux de
partager des moments d'émotion
extrêmement intense avec tout ce qu'on
aime eh bien ça un jour on a envie de ça
arrive cette fois l'enjeu est de taille
l'issue du vote du cio incertaine et la
tension s'exprime avec des mots très
sportif voix soit un peu privilégié et
surtout très nerveux un peu l'impression
de le discuter avant de relever
lorsqu'on a démarré une course
donc elle n'est pas terminée vingt sept
bourses on n'a pas gagné il faut
franchir la ligne d'arrivée est sportif
de haut niveau qui est par une
compétition bain en général est confiant
mais ne surestime pas une et
sous-estiment passée réd hier leur
mission à tous
prêcher la bonne parole et des paris
grâce à leur notoriété leur expérience
olympique sans s'occuper des adversaires
on va pas regarder ce qu'il ya sur les
autres projets ont critiqué ce projet
nous les confions nos projets et voilà
on est serein on attend et mercredi
parker et les siens espère bien
convaincre le monde de l'olympisme
on parle beaucoup de paris et de londres
mais les autres villes candidates y
croient aussi c'est le cas à de madrid
où le soutien populaire est encore plus
fort qu'en france sur place jacques
cardoze andré germain plus de cent mille
bénévoles déjà inscrits annonçant
fièrement en plein coeur de madrid
puerta del sol se déroule en
électronique espère traduire ainsi le
soutien populaire autour de la
candidature espagnole
autre dossier super et comme tout le
monde on espère gagner explique cette
jeune femme chargée d'en voler les
futurs bénévoles
on a déjà organisé les jeux à barcelone
et tout était parfait il n'y a pas eu de
problèmes de sécurité et de contrôle des
personnes
car voilà bien le gros point noir du
dossier madrilène le terrorisme de thé à
l'organisation séparatiste basque a déjà
entaché la candidature en faisant sauter
une voiture piégée à l'intérieur du site
le plus symbolique le stade olympique
al'inverse madrid a déjà réalisé 83 %
des infrastructures prévues
son dossier est sans surprise et surtout
soutenu par l'ancien président du cio
juan antonio samaranch la ville a comme
paris multiplié les initiatives
populaires pourtant à deux jours de la
décision finale
certains madrilènes ont du mal à y
croire
beaucoup d'espagnols pense que c'est
paris qui va gagner parce que madrid
c'est un village qui est devenue une
ville alors que paris c'est déjà une
grande ville mercredi c'est d'ici de la
plaza mayor haut lieu touristique que
les espagnols suivront le vote final
longtemps considéré comme la grande
rivale de paris madrid a semblé marquer
le pas ces derniers temps mais la
capitale espagnole petit croire jusqu'au
bout elle qui n'a jamais organisé les
jeux forte de son argument financier
puisque son projet et le moins onéreux
des cinq villes candidates les vacances
avec ce soir une curiosité réconfortante
sur la capacité de la nature à se
régénérer
il ya un peu plus de 25 ans l'amoco
cadiz répandait des centaines de
milliers de tonnes de pétrole sur les
côtes bretonnes on était venus de toute
la france pour nettoyer et bien
aujourd'hui la marée noire est bien fini
et l'épave est devenu un lieu de plonger
très riche et très couru au large du
finistère romuald bonnan gabriel camille
coûte que coûte ces passionnés de
plongée doivent paris pour une rencontre
de quelques dizaines de minutes
seulement entre de marée un rendez vous
avec un colosse qui depuis 27 ans se
cache à plus de 3 km des côtes bretonnes
sommes brouillés sur la poupe sur
l'arrière de la moto cadix le haut de la
poupe se trouvera à -6 7 mètres et
l'arrière est à -28 dans une obscurité
quasi totale tout à coup les papes de
l'amoco cadiz se dessine gisant à 45
degrés sur un lit de sable
du superpétrolier de 300 mètres de long
c'est surtout la partie arrière avec son
gouvernail qui a le mieux résisté à la
pression sous-marine un monstre dont
l'âme se fait parfois entendre dans
l'agro cercueil pour les plongeurs
l'épave est devenue un lieu de
pèlerinage
car dans les cuves éventré la faune et
la flore ont trouvé refuge des pubs
jadis plein de pétrole
c'est un focus train de voir par quoi
car au même endroit ce 17 mars 78 la
mère vit le pire des cauchemars en se
brisant l'amoco cadiz libère 200 mille
tonnes de fioul lourd souillant des
dizaines de kilomètres de côtes avant de
sombrer à jamais beaucoup de plongeurs
aime plonger sur les épaves pour sas et
c'est un des hobbies favori des
plongeurs et plonger sur une épave qui
faisait 330 mètres de long et 50 mètres
de large
c'est quand même un truc à faire au
moins une fois l'amoco cadiz dans la
partie avant avec son bulbe est
introuvable
un reste d'épaves mythique que les
plongeurs rêve de découvrir dans un
autre genre maintenant l'arrivée des
camping-cars géant cela ce passe
évidemment aux états unis ce sont de
véritables camion avec une surface
habitable de plus de 20 mètres carrés
les maisons roulantes pour sillonner le
pays
il faut quand même avoir les moyens plus
de 200000 euros pour les plus gros
d'entre eux pascal golomer tristan le
bras sur place en californie avec ses 12
mètres de long il ad ailleurs d'autobus
mais il se conduit comme une voiture
c'est en tout cas ce que promet loup
garcia sa femme et lui sont devenus les
inconditionnels du camping-car modèle
extra-large le classe a comme on
l'appelle autres spécialités j'aime
cette vue panoramique
on domine de la route et on voit des
paysages qu'on pouvait voir auparavant
et en cas de besoin et diffic se lever
pour aller aux toilettes à l'arrière
malheureusement pour voir du pays
il faut passer souvent à la pompe
l'engin consomme allègrement 40 litres
d'essence aux 100 km mais la liberté de
s'installer où bon vous semble
cela n'a pas de prix sur un parking au
bord d'une plage de californie ou dans
l'un des innombrables parc privé
construit sur mesure pour ces géants des
géants qui se déploie une fois garé
histoire de gagner encore quelques
mètres carrés d'espacé supplémentaire
bien sur l'auvent est électrique et se
replient automatiquement si le vent
devient trop fort ça ne ressemble plus
vraiment à de la grande aventure mêlée
garcia sont comme ça ils aiment leur
confort l'intérieur bois et la moquette
épaisse
on sent chez soi même loin de chez nous
j'ai 64 ans et je n'ai vu que trois
états dans magnum alors maintenant je
vais découvrir la nouvelle angleterre le
canada et le reste du pays
du coup les constructeurs américains se
bousculent pour répondre à la demande
dans dance ford nous fait visiter le
modèle haut de gamme qu'il vend 200
mille euros pièce venez pas ici je vais
vous montrer
alors là c'est la douche avec un puits
de lumière initale vous voyez le placard
est assez grand pour loger toute la
famille l'intérieur est en cèdre avec
télé satellite et reconditionnés c'est
vraiment un très beau modèle et si
l'intérieur ne vous plaît pas aucun
problème tout les sur mesure le blanc
comme les matériaux
nos ventes ont triplé ces dernières
années parce qu'il ya de plus en plus de
gens qui ont les moyens de s'offrir un
beau jouer comme ça ils veulent voyager
comme de là
jeunesse mais ils sont prêts à dépenser
beaucoup comme lou et mildred une fois
la retraite arrivée ils sont aussi des
milliers chaque année à vendre le chalet
à la montagne ou le studio avec vue sur
mer pour investir dans l'une de ses
résidences secondaires sur quatre roues
pas de jardin peut-être mais l'amérique
à découvrir
or le tour de france 2e étape en ligne
et deuxième victoire au sprint à tour
cette fois pour le belge boonen
zabriskie conserve son maillot jaune
juste devant armstrong nathanaël de
rincquesen emmanuel bec à le voir ainsi
discuté avec le maillot jaune
on se dit que pour lance armstrong le
tour de france est un jeu d'enfant dans
la vallée de la loire la troisième étape
de château en château et prend parfois
des allures de promenade touristique un
décor de rêve pour les rois de la petite
reine pour les trois échappés du jour en
revanche pas le temps d'admirer le
paysage
bordas le penser bertogliatti le suisse
decker le néerlandais lutte contre le
vent
190 km d'effort
derrière tranquillement le peloton
refait son retard à trois kilomètres de
la ligne d'arrivée à tour nicolas portal
et ses copains d'un jour doivent rendre
les armes
le jeune français est battu mais il en
faudrait plus pour lui s'appelle moral
devant les caméras à la télé ça les
copains qui me plaît comme hier la
victoire se joue au sprint sa fraude
fort pour être aux premières places on
assiste même un curieux tête à tête
entre na kiwanja o'grady comme hier tom
boonen se montre le plus rapide
le belge remporte sa deuxième victoire
en deux jours l'américain david
zabriskie lui continue de voir la vie en
jaune
et puis les images du week-end comme
chaque lundi c'est le nouveau pari
réussi de steve fossett l'aventurier
américain ces lanceurs a traversée de
l'atlantique à bord d'un biplan pour
reproduire le premier vol sans escale
entre l'amérique et le biais l'irlande
c'était en 1919
steve fossett et son copilote ont
atterri hier après plus de 16 heures de
voyage musique pour terminer avec le
retour du groupe louise attaque vous
souvenez sûrement de leur premier tube
de leur premier refrain il avait vendu
près de trois millions et demi d'albums
à la fin des années 90 et bien après
quatre ans de séparation le groupe s'est
reformé il fait la tournée des festivals
de l'été
holliday les news high and one quatre
ans que l'on ne l'avait pas entendu le
violon de louise attaque virevoltent à
nouveau
le nom du groupe vous est familier le
visage des musiciens un peu moins louise
attaque trois millions et demi d'albums
vendus dans la discrétion en se tenant à
l'écart des médias
séparés depuis 2001 le groupe se reforme
et nous ouvre ses portes
une première
on a passé un certain temps sans être
ensemble sont jouées ensemble donc
fatalement on est revenues chacun de
nous avec ce qu'on avait vécu en tant
qu'être humain donc on la réinjecter
donc on a retrouvé des choses et des
idées et des réflexes qu'on a entre nous
dans la manière de jouer avec aussi ce
qu'ont à 2,9 pour fêter son retour
louise attaque a organisé à paris son
propre festival
l'occasion pour le bund interpréter
quelques titres de l'album qui sortira
en septembre
amoureux
si fait
j'ai deux
tout est flou
cette chanson extraite du prochain
disque n'est pas distribué en magasin
mais peut-être téléchargé via internet
sur des sites ayant sorti un single en
magasin ça peut être un peu la promo
tout ça un peu tapageur donc on s'est
dit par le biais d'internet c'était
vachement intéressant c'est aussi une
façon dire qu'on a pas plan 12 internet
dit est-ce que tu m'aimes encore dit est
ce que tu vois si si on brasse ou sinon
mais pourquoi tu m'as dit est-ce que tu
m'aimes encore pour les fans la réponse
est évidente après quatre ans d'absence
ce titre inédit prouve que le haut
possède toujours l'art de la mélodie
ça valait la vue
oui
le rock français n'a qu'à bien se tenir
louis ltte retour contre attaque fin de
ce journal merci d'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo isabelle martinet 20h55
intervilles là aussi c'est un retour
intervilles autour de nagui et de
patrice laffont et beaucoup d'autres
12h45 dernier journal ont expliqué dès
6h30 télématin dans les 4 vérités gérard
leclerc recevra dominique strauss kahn
on se quitte sur ces images magnifiques
le mariage du feu et de l'eau ce volcan
sous marin est entré en éruption dans le
pacifique au sud du japon
la vapeur s'élève sur plus d'un
kilomètre le site est connu la dernière
éruption date de 1986 elle avait duré
trois ans à demain